hey look at this
now look at this
this is Opel it's a birth control pill
that's finally available over the
counter but there are a bunch of other
options that are just as safe and
effective and are much more convenient
for women to use but none of them are
available without a prescription just a
pill because the FDA won't let you buy
them over the counter here's why Opel is
a progestin only pill most birth control
pills are combination pills meaning they
contain both estrogen and progestin but
the FDA chose o pill because it can be
taken by women who are breastfeeding or
who are heavy smokers even though
doctors still consider combination pills
safe for example there is a higher risk
of blood clots during pregnancy than an
on combination
so it's great that Opel is finally
available over the counter but it's not
so great that the FDA is still
restricting choices women can make about
their own health